ليلى سنبدا باخر تحديث الان من وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه الحديث عن ثلاثه اصابات
مؤكده وصلت الى المستشفى بينها اصابه
خطيره في الصدر ولكن لنجمل ما يحدث في
الساعه الاخيره وفق اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تم اغتيال اربعه مسلحين
فلسطينيين من بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره
لنذكر هنا بان ان كان ذلك صحيح فنتحدث عن
الهجوم الذي نفذه مسلح فلسطيني قبل تسعه
ايام في بلده حواره وادى الى مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين حوار هي جنوب نابلس ان صحت
تلك المعلومات فهذا معناه ان تسعه ايام
كانت كل اذرع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحاول
الوصول الى منفذ العمليه الذي تمكن ان صحت
هذه المعلومات من الوصول جنوب نابلس مرورا
بنابلس فعده مدن وصولا الى مدينه ومخيم
جنين ولكن حتى اللحظه لا يمكن تاكيد ذلك
الا بعد صدور بيان الرسمي من وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه التي عاده ما تتلقى هكذا
معلومات عبر الارتباط المدني الفلسطيني
بعد ابلاغ الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رسميا
السلطه الفلسطينيه باستشهاد احد ولكن وفق
ايضا المعلومات المؤكده الاشتباكات
المسلحه لا زالت متواصله وتحديدا في
المنطقه الشرقيه
للمخيم في منطقه تعرف بشارع مهيوب ما حدث
ان قوه من المستعربين دخلت كما دخلت قبل
ايام الى مدينه اريحا ومخيم عقبه جابر
بفان سياره بيضاء كبيره دخل فيها عدد من
المستعربين تسللوا الى المخيم ومن ثم تم
استدعاء قوات كبيره من قوات الاحتلال لدعم
هذه القوه تم محاصره عدد من المنازل ومن
ثم تم محاصره منزل واحد بعينه وفق المصادر
التابعه لقوات الاحتلال فانه تم اطلاق
صاروخ واحد على الاقل على هذا المنزل الذي
اكد ايضا شهود عيان ان هناك اصوات كانت
تسمع من داخل هذا المنزل هناك طائره
عموديه مروحيه تابعه للاحتلال لا زالت
تحوم في الاجواء ولكن فقط هنا للتوضيح
ليله انتم تحدثتم عن ان هكذا عمليه هي
مستغربه بالتوقيت نذكر هنا مجزره مدينه
نابلس قبل اسبوعين قوات الاحتلال دخلت في
وضح النهار دخلت تقريبا الساعه العاشره
الحاديه عشره صباحا نفذت مجزره في وضح
النهار كان هناك اشتباكات مسلحه ولكن
اطلقت النار بشكل عشوائي فسقط احد عشر
شهيدا اذا قوات الاحتلال لم تعد تعتمد فقط
على العمليات السريعه والخاطفه في ساعات
الليل والفجر ولكن الان بدات تدخل الى
المدن والقرى الفلسطينيه في وضح النهار هي
تضع نصب اعينها بالطبع مدينتي نابلس وجنين
ولكن راينا ما حدث ايضا في مخيم عقبه جابر
عقب مقتل مستوطن اسرائيلي الاسبوع الماضي
راينا ايضا ما حدث في اكثر من منطقه
المجزره او المذبحه حسب وصف حتى الخارجيه
الامريكيه ما حدث في بلده حواره عاقبه
مقتل
المستوطنين والان ما يدور الحديث عنه انه
تم استهداف منفذ هذه العمليه ولكن نحن
لازلنا بانتظار بيانات جديده من وزاره
الصحه
الفلسطينيه هناك حديث عن
على ما يبدو شيء في نابلس ولكن ذلك غير
مؤكد ولكن ما نؤكد حسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه هو ثلاث اصابات بينها اصابه
خطيره لا نتحدث هنا عن الشبان المحاصرين
في داخل المنزل نتحدث هنا عن اصابات برصاص
قوات الاحتلال خارج هذه المنطقه بسبب
الرصاص الحي الذي اطلقه جنود الاحتلال
بشكل عشوائي